good evening and welcome to tucker
carl's tonight for all the bad things
going on there are on the other side joe
biden's approval ratings which are a
nonstop source of joy for us and if
you've seen them recently you know in
your heart exactly how the november
elections are going to turn out biden's
obviously been a disaster for the
country but not only has he made the u.s
poor weaker and much more ridiculous
people know that he has and they tell
pollsters about it all the time biden is
the single least popular president in
modern american history at this point
absolutely nobody is impressed by joe
biden and that would be
including dr jill so this is a big
problem for the biden family obviously
but a much bigger problem even for the
democratic party which joe biden leads
unpopular presidents drag their parties
to the bottom in midterm elections
that's the unchanging rule of politics
you saw it famously in 1994 with the
republican takeover of congress after
two disastrous years with bill clinton
you saw it in 2006 after hurricane
katrina you saw it in 2010 after
obamacare you saw it in 2018.
so there's no question based on
precedent that that's about to happen
once again in 2022 in november that's
what everybody assumes and in fact it
may well happen we're certainly praying
for it but as of tonight we have to be
honest with you the numbers don't show
that happening
not even close in fact all the
indications we have right now
suggest that despite joe biden's
well-earned unpopularity the democratic
party still again as of tonight has a
strong chance of holding congress in
november
the prediction markets which many
believe are more accurate than the polls
overwhelmingly point to the democrats
keeping at least one chamber
and maybe strangers of all as of this
week democrats are leading republicans
nationally on the so-called generic
ballot by about four points so if you
ask people which party do you like more
they say democrats
and maybe that's why democrats are
raising a lot more money too and not
just money from their patrons in big
tech but from small dollar donors that's
bad
in june democrats raised 64 million
dollars online from 4 million people
that same month this june republicans
raised only 26 million dollars online
from just over a million donors
from the first quarter to the second
quarter of this year donations to the
republican party dropped by more than 12
percent
by contrast donations the democratic
party are up more than 20 percent that
is not good at all not simply because
you need money to run a political
campaign but because money is to some
extent a measure of commitment and
intensity
and you see the same dynamic playing out
in individual races across the country
for example
last quarter raphael warnock that would
be the thoroughly mediocre democratic
senator from georgia the guy who was
caught on video appearing to commit
spousal abuse remember that that guy
raised more than 12 million dollars
online
his opponent herschel walker who
everyone likes raised less than half of
that
so far rafael warnock has raised an
astounding amount of money he's hauled
in more dollars online than seven
republican senatorial candidates
combined candidates in north carolina
pennsylvania nevada ohio florida
wisconsin and georgia combined
herschel walker is now trailing raphael
warnock by 10 points and this is
happening in a state they tell us went
for joe biden by a margin of about
one-third of a percentage point
that is bizarre what is going on here
it's not just happening in georgia
according to the official numbers you'll
recall joe biden won the state of
pennsylvania by a little over a single
percentage point in 2020 so it's been
two years
biden has become much less popular since
then meanwhile pennsylvania which is
controlled by the democratic party has
become much worse
far more chaotic and dangerous here was
the scene in the state's largest city on
tuesday
nearly 100 shots fired on 57th street
between haverford and westminster
tonight a sea of evidence markers lined
this west philly street telling of the
potentially deadly chaos that unfolded
here responding officers found four
victims on 57th street two shot in the
head in critical condition tonight one
victim we're told in a bmw is an
innocent bystander caught in gunfire and
shot in the shoulder all while kids and
young adults were on a nearby playground
over a hundred shots right in the middle
of the street
it's hard to believe that's an american
city it's hard to believe that's the
place where our constitution was written
it's totally unacceptable and it wasn't
organic it didn't just happen this is a
result of policies from the democratic
party
period
now you'd think this being a democracy
that voters would punish anyone who had
anything to do with turning philadelphia
into the disaster you just saw
and john fetterman certainly did have a
hand in that he's the sitting lieutenant
governor of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania federer now wants a new job
he's running for the u.s senate
he's the candidate in some ways john
fetterman is the weakest possible
candidate you could run he has obviously
a very public record of failure he also
had a devastating stroke this spring
which is sad
but it affected him here he is
campaigning for senate you can count
on
us to eliminate the filibuster
if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stand with you in dc
and let's let's get some stuff
done for america i gave away the
lieutenant governor governor in
pennsylvania the only lieutenant
governor in the history to do that
so this guy is everything you'd think
wouldn't work he's radical for one thing
let's eliminate the filibuster oh good
idea john fetterman he's implicated in
the destruction of the state that he's
still the lieutenant governor of and
he's obviously impaired that's not an
attack on him it's just true watch him
so you'd think there would be no way a
guy like that could win a senate seat
and here's the sad news however john
fetterman is winning overwhelmingly he
currently has a double-digit lead over
his republican opponent mehmet oz dr oz
the national republican senatorial
committee just slashed its spending in
the state of pennsylvania by more than
five million dollars including their ad
buys in the city of philadelphia
that's a retreat and it's happening in a
state that republicans ought to be
winning what is going on here and why is
no one mentioning it
well a couple of things are going on but
first let's hear from mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell is the head republican
in the senate he's not there because
everyone likes him mcconnell has no
close friends he's loved by no one but
he's considered very smart
he is a master tactician as the dummies
who cover politics where politico and
the washington post are always telling
us
in washington people are very much
afraid of mitch mcconnell cross him and
he will hurt you
and they listen carefully to his
political analysis because that's what
he spent his life doing that's the only
thing he spent his life doing so here's
what mitch mcconnell says the problem is
watch there's probably a greater
likelihood of house flips
than the senate
senate races are just different they're
statewide
candidate quality has a lot to do with
the outcome
so there's the
head republican in the senate conceding
three months out that republicans are
probably not going to retake the senate
why is that well the answer of course
was in the final line you just heard
some of the candidates
are mediocre that's mitch mcconnell's
excuse and there's some truth in that
obviously some of them are mediocre
but compared to what
mediocre in the congress let's see
dianne feinstein hasn't spoken a
coherent sentence in years hasn't had
trouble getting reelected eric swallow
had sex with a chinese spy he's still
there
so mediocre people get elected to office
lots and lots and lots of them do every
cycle
so what mcconnell's analysis really is
of course is buck passing don't blame me
i didn't choose these people
all right
but they're still the nominees
so if you want to save the country and
move in a different direction yes using
some mediocre people to do it what are
you going to do
no hint of what you might do for mitch
mcconnell other than just accept the
inevitable now the truth is it's
entirely possible mitch mcconnell
doesn't want to retake the senate
because then you'd have to run things
and there's one thing republican leaders
dislike it's running anything much
easier to complain on fox news
but if you actually wanted to win what
would you do well here's an idea just
kind of out of nowhere just spitballing
here how about you run on issues that
voters care about that might work even
for a mediocre candidate so let's say
again just for the sake of argument the
urana campaign on illegal immigration
and crime
now these are two issues that didn't
just arise out of nowhere they're the
product of policies the democratic party
put in
they were intentional outcomes we have
millions of people coming in illegally
and we have a lot more murders than we
had two years ago
these two issues immigration and crime
don't simply annoy voters though they
very much do
these two issues threaten the existence
of our society
so maybe you should run on them that
seems reasonable but that's not what
they're doing oh no
here for example is a recent campaign ad
from dr oz he's the guy who's losing to
the stroke victim in pennsylvania watch
i thought he doesn't grocery shopping
i'm at work nurse and my wife wants some
vegetables for true today right so
here's a broccoli that's two bucks
without a ton of broccoli there there's
some asparagus that's four dollars yep
carrots
that's four more dollars that's ten
dollars of vegetables there and then
we need some guacamole that's four
dollars more
and
she loves salsa yeah salsa there
six dollars
must be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute this doesn't
include the tequila i mean that's
outrageous we got joe biden to thank for
this
twenty dollars for a credit day
whatever that is it's obviously very
easy to make fun of that
but it's not entirely a stupid ad
if immigra if
inflation
were
the salient issue here the generational
issue of this campaign season but it's
not
inflation's terrible it's making people
poorer we actually could tank the us
dollar these are all big big problems
but changing the population of the
united states allowing people to be
murdered in the street letting drug
addicts live on the sidewalk and sending
them crack pipes that will change
everything forever these are offenses
against the most basic rules of any
civilization and the most basic of all
is you reward people for doing the right
thing and you penalize them for doing
the wrong thing if you start doing the
opposite then everything falls apart and
everybody knows that so why not just say
it want to just say that don't be
embarrassed just say that
if you live in texas for example a
supposedly conservative state
you don't even have police protection
anymore that's how quickly things have
changed on the most basic level that's
not some report from a government agency
telling you what the inflation rate is
that's your life you don't have police
protection anymore if there's one reason
to run for office it's to fix things
like that
here's fox reporter madison all worth
describing it
in dallas they are unable to fill the
nearly 600 openings that they have
budgeted for
in atlanta they have over 400 openings
that they cannot fill even with an up to
four thousand dollar signing bonus
police department has been demonized
across the country in communities across
the country from coast to coast it's
been demonized if that police officer in
uniform is not on your corner we're
seeing the results the staffing crisis
is creating crime it's creating violence
you take a look at crime across the u.s
and it is way up robbery is up nearly 20
percent in chicago and los angeles and
here in new york city up nearly 40
percent
okay uh
crudites 20 bucks got it
but
that
that's more important than everything
else that's going on right now
law and order you see it on the streets
of our cities you see it at our southern
border it's collapsed
so if you're a republican voter and not
just a republican voter any voter
you probably want to know
what is the government going to do about
the fact that i can call 9-1-1 and no
one shows up
what are you going to do about the fact
that our border is open to the world and
that millions of them have come in
illegally how can you take the country
seriously when it doesn't even have a
border
and it doesn't and we know that because
on video every single day
people stream in
fox's building just caught the whole
thing once again on camera take a look
at this video we shot yesterday where
we're standing this is the first time we
had ever seen this the texas national
guard closed and locked a gate on this
property it's a major crossing area and
they blocked the illegal immigrants from
being able to come into this property
it's private property the owner allows
the national guard and border patrol to
work here but you can see illegal
immigrants started showing up they
weren't let in they expected to be let
in and they were surprised they couldn't
get in here's what happened though take
a look at this video border patrol
showed up a supervisor came with a key
opened up that gate and let all of those
illegal immigrants in symbolic of the
way the state of texas handles things
versus the way the federal government
handles things
so if every republican candidate is
repeated repeat after me
law enforcement law and order is not
racist law and order is a prerequisite
for civilization and if it goes away so
does the country you would win the votes
not simply of your own voters
but of a lot of other voters and people
who have never voted before and any
normal democrat would agree with that
because it's inherently true but it's
the opposite of what we have as when ann
coulter saw the
video we just played she noted correctly
that it's easier to get into this
country as an illegal alien than it is
to return as an american citizen back
into jfk
by the way the people you saw the ones
who just want to be caught they're
turning themselves in so they give bus
to your town
a lot of people who don't want to be
caught and those people are bringing in
fentanyl which is killing thousands of
americans every month
it's been a busy few weeks for u.s
customs and border protection officers
in nogales at the checkpoint on saturday
they found 2.5 pounds of black tar
heroin nine pounds of heroin 89 pounds
of meth and 320 thousand fentanyl pills
later that day another huge bust
including more than 40 pounds of drugs
and 150 thousand fentanyl pills hidden
in a car border officials say people are
becoming more creative in the ways they
smuggle items through in one case
someone tried to hide 10 thousand
fentanyl pills using a body shaping
garment
everybody knows this is happening this
is not hidden information these are not
the gnostic gospels every american
citizen knows exactly what's happening
and yet the leaders of the republican
party mitch mcconnell will watch footage
like that until you know that the most
important issue that we face territorial
integrity of ukraine
and then the same breath which there's
nothing the republican party can do to
avert historic humiliation in the
midterm elections but the truth as you
well know
is that the people who run the
republican party don't actually want to
do anything about it there are
candidates who are talking about this
stuff jd vance in ohio blake masters in
arizona joe kent
in the pacific northwest
the leaders of the republican party in
washington would rather those guys lose
and people like them lose
than change the focus of the party to
issues that voters actually care about
but the truth is you can't win elections
unless you listen to voters they're
telling you what they want
republicans have less than three months
to figure this very simple riddle out or
it's going to be an actual disaster
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight